un remède sûr et efficace c'est ce que
promettent les autorités espagnoles pour
leurs populations
un vaccin gratuit annonce le ministre de
la santé salvadori à en détaillant la
stratégie du gouvernement
le vaccin coville 19 sera un vaccin
gratuit qui sera administré par le biais
du système de santé national tout comme
les autres vaccins du calendrier de
vaccination actuelle nous allons nous
concentrer sur quatre groupes
spécifiques des maisons de retraite
le personnel de santé qui s'occupe des
maisons de retraite
le reste du personnel de santé les
personnes handicapées qui ont besoin de
soins ou qui sont dans un établissement
de santé
140 millions de doses seront disponibles
d'après le ministre de la santé
de quoi immunisés 80 millions de
personnes bien plus que les 47 millions
d'espagnols
le gouvernement explique ainsi vouloir
faire profiter de l'excédent de doses à
des pays qui en auraient besoin
en dehors de l'union européenne ce
vaccin suscite beaucoup d'espoirs dans
la péninsule ibérique mais certains
restent méfiants quant à la sûreté du
remède
je pense que le vaccin est toujours
conseillé une fois qu'il a été
suffisamment testés et qu'il s'est avéré
efficace
je pense qu'il est bon de se faire
vacciner parce que nous savons que le
vaccin est efficace quand la plupart des
gens se vaccine je préfère attendre je
ne prendrais pas le risque de me
vacciner maintenant
non ils ne peuvent pas dire que cela se
fasse dans les centres de santé sans
plus de précisions mais il faudra
organiser des points de vaccination
correctement pris en charge par le
personnel nécessaire pour que cela
puisse être fait de manière sûre
rigoureuse et adéquate
mais au-delà de cela je pense que nous
les médecins nous collaborons toujours
premièrement nous attendons les vaccins
que l'administration nous annonce
ensuite assurons nous que les vaccins
soient sûres car le personnel de santé
nous avons des doutes quant à
l'innocuité des vaccins et enfin cela
doit être bien organisé il faut donc ne
nombreuses réunions et se préparer dès
maintenant pour pouvoir vacciner encore
dans huit mois
mais nous devons préparer cela dès
maintenant
et l'espagne est l'un des pays européens
les plus touchés par la pandémie
on dénombre de l'autre côté des pyrénées
plus de quarante trois mille décès pour
près d'un million six cent mille cas
confirmés